ننتقل الى بريطانيا حيث ذكرت وسائل اعلام
ان ثلاثه من طالب اللجوء على الاقل لقوا
مصرعهم وان السلطات تمكنت من انقاذ اكثر
من من كانوا علمتني قارب غرق في القناه
للانجليزيه واكد مسؤول الحكومه وطوارئ في
بريطانيا وقوع الحادث وافادوا بان قوارب
النجاه و طائرات الهليكوبتر وفرق الانقاذ
تعمل حاليا مع القوات البحريه الفرنسيه
والبريطانيه للاستجابه للحادث الذي وقع في
حوالي الساعه الثالثه واربعين دقيقه صباحا
تذكر ان بريطانيا تعرضت لموجه من درجات
الحراره المنخفضه الاسبوع الماضي ما ادى
الى تساقط الثلوج في بعض انحاء البلاد
ينضم الينا من لندن مراسل الجزيره اسد
الله الصاوي اسد كيف تؤثر الظروف المناخيه
على عمليات الانقاذ والبحث عن اللاجئي عن
اللاجئين من القارب الذي غرق
هذه الظروف البروده الشديده سينما في تلك
المنطقه وفي عرض البحر في الساعه الثالثه
صباحا كل هذه الظروف تجعل عمليات الانقاذ
يجب ان تكون سريعه للغايه لانه فرص البقاء
اي شخص يسقط في الماء في هذه الظروف فرص
دقائق حيا لمده طويله هي فرص ضعيفه
وبالتالي يجب على عمليات الانقاذ ان
تتوجهها بسرعه كبيره وتخرج هؤلاء الاشخاص
من الماء همم البيانات التي تتوفر حتى
الان تشير الى انه تم انقاذ ثلاثه و40 شخص
على متن ذلك القارئ المطاطي حتى الان هناك
عده همم اشخاص في اعداد المفقودين وهناك
ثلاثه او ثلاثه متوفين حتى الان همم حسب
البيانات الصادره عن الجهات الرسميه
البريطانيه همم درجه الحراره هي احد عوامل
التاثير بالت- همم بالتاكيد هناك ايضا
التوقيت هذه همم هذا الوقت هو وقت همم
يعني في قلب الليل وعمليات الانقاذ يجب
همم يعني ان تتعامل مع هذا العائق الاضافي
ليس فقط المياه ليس فقط البروده وانما
ايضا الظلام يجب الاشاره هنا فداء الى ان
بريطانيا او فرنسا مؤخرا اتفاقا لتشديد
الرقابه على الحدود الفرنسيه لمنع
الانطلاق قوارب المهاجرين منها الى
الشواطئ البريطانيه هذا الاتفاق سهم بشكل
ما في تخفيض عدد همم يعني القوارب التي
تنطلق من فرنسا الى بريطانيا ولكنه في همم
الوقت ادى الى همم يعني اقدام بعض
المهاجرين على همم ركوب المخاطر بشكل اكبر
يعني همم انه يخرجون في ساعات متاخره من
الليل يخرجون في ظروف مناخيه سيئه للغايه
كل هذا يصعب عمل هذه السلطات الفرنسيه
والبريطانيه ولكنه من وجهه نظر المهاجرين
المهاجرين يسهل عليهم فكره الوصول الى همم
بريطانيا حتى الان عمليه الانقاذ ما زالت
جاريه حسب السلطات البريطانيه والفرنسيه
لم تتوقف وحتى الان هناك بحث عن همم عده
اشخاص يقدرون بسته على الاقل ما زالوا
مفقودين شكرا لك اسعد الله الصاوي مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من لندن